okay hi everyone we are here to continue
our discussion about historical
countries
and they're rendering databases and time
series for historical shapes for
Geographic shapes and so on so where
should we start
maybe in the one with time series for a
geographical shapes that's why
okay
so
do you have a proposal for how to do
this
uh this is the current status of the
time series for polygons in historical
country data
Is this different from what we looked at
before
not really the first point that I
already made last time can we please
actually fix it is don't have the thing
to the second
okay put this I think that's a
challenging series issue though
but they all have to be the same or what
no right now the the times the dates are
basically with instant granularity so we
do not support uh different
granularities for the time what do you
do if you have different granularities
would they at least coerce them they are
all instantiated too instant right okay
that's fine but so what we should do
here is make
but you should store them okay this
thing here should generate a Time series
that does not say first of January do
you understand what I'm saying
right change that fix it do not do that
well no right but the whole point okay
we talked about this last time the whole
point that time series just forgets
about all granularity information once
it's in the time series that's fine it's
at least yeah okay but is this looking
at the Min of all the times and that and
it's an instant and so it's displaying
it as January 1st I understand I
understand so
but this is wrong here I can already
tell this is wrong
oh I see you're saying the time series
is messing this up the time series
that's in the time series that is a Time
series okay fine but you're saying that
this wouldn't be wrong if I were to look
at this its dates will be correct is
that true
I'm not sure what this is well I'm the
thing I'm highlighting The Entity value
The Entity value is returning the time
series
okay go show what's it going to take to
fix this
or working on you know on the new
version of the time series so
um I hear you with the granularity so
we'll have discussions about that you
know how to deal with the granular you
know times in a Time steps this sounds
like a very long-term project we need
something it is well it is it it is
it is kind of tricky a little bit
there could be something easy to do here
which is just to store some work the
generality and use it in type setting
nothing changes in How Time series works
but the type setting knows that so you
just okay so so there are two two kind
of questions whether you are you want
this in the type setting or you know the
storage that you know or in the storage
in a way we don't care about the storage
okay so what I so for the type setting
that might be a quicker fix and it might
go with the you know existing
um temporal data set up yes
yes because the way the way right now
you you actually see it it's it's
already you know type setting only uh
day uh month and year because we know
that there are zeros
so
um
okay
okay let's just solve it at the level of
type setting for now okay I will I will
look into and I will talk to you
um you know the The Entity
um developers to kind of discuss how to
let let's time series know that we want
to type set this just for the year
okay fine I'm fine
if necessary you can put some option in
the time series for now
that's a granularity option don't we
have a granularity option a name
granularity option what's it called the
deadline writing it has just been
introduced
fine so go sugar just use that
right although I I doubt you'd want to
document it because it won't you know
the actual semantics of Time series no I
understand yes but it might be a
developer option just for the for the
purposes of type setting right monster
okay all right fine so other than that
horror
uh
what
what are we seeing here
so this is Geo area I mean this looks
like it works nicely
what's uh
issue that you pointed out last meeting
was the the fact that at the end of the
time series there is a missing not
available
to Signal the time series that there it
ends that there is no more data so have
you solved that date
did you solve that
and no it's uh also a Time series issue
I don't know okay let's define it kosher
do you know what the issue is
what no I don't know yet I have to okay
all right okay so here's the issue
here's the issue every one of these
polygons is valid for a particular span
of years
okay
but Time series
is not marking time series is just
giving points where this is the value
this is the value this is the value as
opposed to the last one of these which
is really a span this is valid from 12
1938 BC to whatever it is oh no I think
go ahead well to phrase it differently
the problem is that the time series
considers itself you know ended at the
last of the last entry in the time
series but really this time series ends
a little bit later
right because it's got you know
interpolation Arrow you know none or
whatever and so you know it it basically
assumes that between you know data point
A and J to point B
you know between two times it just it
just uses you know the previous polygon
to interpolate but then for the last
polygon
you know the time series just considers
itself over immediately if that makes
sense
here's the point the last data point we
have for the shape of pressure or
something is such and such a thing I
don't know the history of pressure I
know you do but I don't but you know but
but you know the last data point let's
say is is you know 1908 let's say and it
has some shape right
Prussia ended on some date right but we
don't record that the time series
doesn't have
uh you get what I'm saying it doesn't
yes
so basically what happens if you have
the interpolation or the zero it's gonna
hold the last value
yeah it doesn't know until when
so if you if you request if you look so
that's what's gonna happen that if you
request the value at the time after this
1908
um then it's gonna give you the last
value that I understand that but the
whole point is that's why we are adding
they're missing exactly right but the
whole point is let's say it ends in
nineteen
14 I I don't know my history so I'm
sorry I apologize but let's say it ends
in 1914 right so after 1914 there should
be nothing then it should genuinely be
missing but from 1908 to 1914 you should
get the held last value yes
if time series instead of using points
and giving a value at a point gave a
value at an interval then this would
work because then we would just say I
mean the correct thing that is in fact
what this data is saying is from 1908 to
1914 the shape was this
but if you query any date in in this
interval you're gonna get the previous
value which is the the 1908 value
that's fine by the end of the problem is
if you query 1909 it'll actually give a
you know it'll complaint that
extrapolation is being used or something
yes because it has to extrapolate
because right it's because it's going
because it's going outside of the
duration
the truth of this data is we have
polygons for countries for intervals of
dates
we know between 2044 BC and 2032 BC the
shape of the city of UR or whatever it
is here was that
you see what I'm saying we know it for
an interval
well well two things one we don't
necessarily know it for an interval
there are some times I'm sure when when
it's kind of like well we know it here
and we know it there we don't really
know in between or may not have been
well defined at that point the other
thing is that that is exactly what time
series does when there's no
interpolation is it assumes that you
survive these intervals from one day to
the next
right but the problem is outside the
range the finance yeah the time zero
there is no way to define this is
started in this date and ended in the
day
is there a way of just saying a Time
series has these values inside but the
ends of the time series are this and
this the start and end of this
independent of what the values are
is that doable so not yet that we will
discuss that at some point I remember so
we would like to have a different you
know we want to interpolate inside the
the start and end and then have say
return missing or no no you know or none
or something outside of your domain so
we cannot do it right now but
we'll we'll try to incorporate that all
right what is the best hack we can do
right now sorry go ahead one hack that
we discussed last time but but I don't
I'm not sure if we finish the discussion
about that was just just you know take
the polygon for 1908 and have another
copy of it in 1910 or whenever the
actual end date is right so if you ever
query anything in between 1908 and 1910
they'll get the correct polygon and it
will end at the correct date and
everything the only problem is that if
you ask for all the list of values the
last one will appear twice but I don't
think that's that big a deal but why why
would you put it at the uh no no do you
understand ghost you've got to be able
to get if you query between 1908 and
1914 it's got to give that last polygon
but outside if you query it for 1915
it's got to say missing right but it
means that are now at the at the end of
the like what what you have that the
last date would be the missing so you
added the value I think this is the hack
that you're you're yes right it's adding
the missing value no no no two hacks are
discussed one one hack is adding missing
open close at 1914 right so that way
when you query any time before 1914
it'll work but if you query 1914 itself
it'll say missing yes the other hack is
to to instead of doing missing just do
whatever the last polygon you know of
was which has the same effect except
when you ask for 1914 exactly it'll give
you a polygon
well I mean the 1914 1915 I mean we that
that the question of when what okay the
two possibilities are when you look at
the list of polygons you can either have
a reduplication at the end
or you can have a missing
tail actually I think the missingtail
might be better than the reduplicated
tail
I think it would work better logically
at least for me if you put the missing
on the first kind of data that you know
that it's applicable because because up
to that date everything queried before
should have hold the value from that
right okay so so missing look maybe if
it says if it said missing country
stopped existing or something instead of
not available
then it would seem to me to make decent
sense
missing what would we say
uh it shouldn't be the country not
existing because there are things like
uh you know Roman Republic Roman Empire
yeah right what can we say that but not
if we if we made it something that
actually speaks to what happened to the
data rather than just generically saying
not available I think the solution is
fine
so what could it say the only thing the
context I think in which they'll see
this is when you have the time series
and you say bracket values or something
exactly so it shouldn't be confusing you
know well but if it says that date and
then it says missing uh
uh what could it say Geographic entity
discontinued missing discontinued what's
a good word for discontinued that um
um is this one of the end of something
end of string and the file end of data
yeah it's something like that
but
um
yeah the only problem
is that when you map over the values Etc
you will also map over this missing
value right so that's that's true that's
life
that's look well but it's important
because you say Geo area if you say Geo
area
that that's right that was the issue is
if you if you do the time series map of
Geo area over it the last one will freak
out and if it doesn't freak out it'll
return missing you know even if you
handle it correctly you're gonna make it
return missing there which is wrong
because you do actually know what the
area was at least you know two hours
earlier if you know what I mean
that's why another possibility would be
to have an empty polygon and then it
returns zero
but I think that's wrong too because if
you do the Roman Republic thing it
shouldn't say that you know area goes
down to zero at the end
I think it should just say that the you
know I don't know what end date they
have in you know 44 BC or something you
know the that that it should say the
area is whatever it is it should drop to
zero for just as a moment okay listen
guys guys we are dealing with a hack
here hopefully soon time series will you
know have be better stronger and will
not need us to make do a hack
so we've got two possible hats we've got
the reduplication hack or we've got the
missing tail hack
okay to me the missing tail hack seems
better right now it seems a little bit
more honest than the other one
um and I think with a you know so then
all we need here is
um
you know entity doesn't exist anymore
basically is what what it needs to say
right entity missing
what would be the missing non-existent
what's a good word for that
also we should consider the fact that
there are cases where this missing might
happen in the middle of the entity not
available then say not available for
those missings
this is a very specific missing this
missing denotes this entity doesn't
exist anymore
I I don't know well what do we say when
you when you use uh you know dated of
Roman Republic comma 1920. does it just
say missing not available
guys guys here's an issue let's say
there's a country
and it was occupied for some period of
time
and then it came back back again
what does our time series look like in
that case
so at least
sorry go ahead I just want to give you
an example of such country where you can
see I don't know what happens but
I think
yeah you can look at it I think what it
does is they just have a pre you know
pre-war Poland then occupied
earlier
1700 to you know 1930 or something okay
with the partition yeah yeah the
partition
uh
um
dated I think of Poland
uh
comma or
you need a polygon as well
somewhere oh yeah well and you need
historical kind of knowledge base failed
with error code 503 guys is current down
um could somebody look please is current
down
no apparently not well who knows okay so
you're saying this thing
that is there
country data entity that's not the
historical country Poland
how do I get the historical country
uh
it would be in the historical country
okay but I need an answer better than
that because we need to be able to
actually give users a way to get to that
right how are users supposed to get to
that
foreign
usually it does have a it usually does
have an under that menu historical
country thing I would check that there
is in fact a Poland historical country
that's called Poland yeah probably there
isn't
it doesn't do it might be a kingdom of
Poland or something like that duchy of
Commonwealth yes oh okay
Poland is a little bit several entities
is the historic country so does that so
what is that one that will be absorbed
and then reappear again or not yes
okay but but this will just have an end
date which is the partition and then it
will disappear you know this entity will
disappear forever and then it will
reappear as a new thing called Poland
and there used to be a way I don't know
what it's called there used to be a a
property where it gave you something
like it would say polish and you could
look at all the ones that were polish
okay well guys several points first of
all in the entity structure we should
surely have forward and back pointers
so the political polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth should have something a
property that says you know successor
entities or something
does that make sense to people
yeah although that's a deeply fraught
issue I mean here it's pretty obvious
from the name you know it's going to
point to Poland with Lithuania but there
are other cases
no I understand that but I mean at least
I don't know you know
right and you have to it's somewhat
arbitrary because it's like in the case
of
you know
the Roman Empire or something you know
what does it when it fragments to lots
of things
but we do know what was on that land on
that territory the day after it
disappeared that entity disappeared but
I mean even something like what is the
uh you know what is the successor of the
Soviet Union is it just Russia or is it
Russia and every other ex-soviet state
and you know Does it include no I think
et cetera I think it includes Estonia I
think it includes anything whose
territory was encompassed by the
predecessor entity
this is a concept like no boring
countries but it's no boring in
space-time that's correct
but then you also have weird things
maybe this is correct but for example
during the Polish partition I mean
basically you know what was it three
other countries basically just just
absorbed Poland so would they all then
be successors of the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth yes I would think so
if those who wouldn't be able to get the
thing you want if what you want is you
want all the polands you wouldn't get
that you would say what are the
successors the post Lithuanian
Commonwealth and it would tell you I
don't even remember what it is but it's
like Prussia Russia and something else
austro-hungarian Empire there you go
right
um okay and then if you ask for the
successors of those you would not get I
mean you get millions of things yeah I
understand what you're saying because
because one notion of successor is
anything whose territory overlaps the
territory of the predecessor
that's one definition
I agree this is a fraught thing yeah
okay but what we what we're looking at
here we were looking at countries that
what happens to the time series for
countries that disappear that reappear
again
but I think it's a very simple answer
which we've already seen by looking at
the structure of the entities which is
that the time series just ends when the
country disappears and there's a quote
unquote new country that shows up when
the country reappears so there's no
distance
hold on what happened I mean again I
don't know my history well enough but
you know during the second world war for
example when France was Belgium was
occupied right it isn't a different
Belgium before the before the second
world war and after the second world war
is it
I think it is
here it is it'll be a kingdom of Belgium
before and then Belgium afterward or
something like that
is that really right and there's even
stuff like for France we have like Vichy
France and stuff like that yeah right
but is that really right I mean
okay it was occupied and didn't change
you know it was Kingdom before and then
after the second World War II the second
one okay so let's look at that let's
look at what we do from Norway how do we
find that structure so if you just want
to get around these interpretation
things you can just do interpreter of
historical country if you just if all
you want is the
whatever I mean
I'm confused I'm confused I mean we've
got to do better than this
okay it's called currently yeah but so
what happens if I say dated a polygon
comma
1942 I'm going to guess it was occupied
was it
yes
fascinating okay so now if I go back
and I say 1935
oh come on what's going on I should
check if any of the dateds work and also
I don't need a list around the date
otherwise it interprets as an absolute
time
um
you're looking at this regular countries
identity right
yeah
just in historical country but then we
don't what is the historical country of
Norway called
there's one called Denmark Norway one
called oh there's a couple called
Kingdom of Norway there's medieval
Kingdom of Norway there's one just
called Norway but then why is the one
that's just called Norway not showing up
as an alternate in the Linguistics of
Norway
because I don't think we have added
spellings for the the countries in
historical country data that are
equivalent to the modern day countries
because we haven't wanted to have those
clashes in the past it doesn't mean we
can't add those
okay so hold on a second so
I mean isn't this something a little bit
like the hierarchical entity business
but Norway is the instantaneous current
Norway but it has sort of apparent thing
maybe that is the historical sequence of
Norway
um I don't know if that's a hierarchical
relationship
okay so what should we do with this
somebody's turning a message yeah it's
just a list of all the Norway entities
oh
what's all this junk
this is a mess guys sorry I mean history
is the best as we know but um
uh
all right so let's go back through this
again
so first point is I want to know
the borders of Norway
in
1925
how do I get that information
is there a linguistic way to get it what
do I do here I mean again some of these
like
I mean did we especially rename I mean
that Kingdom of Norway 1814 colon
whatever
what is that
how many of those weird things like that
are there
that double colon random junk thing is a
convention that we've been adding to a
lot more domains because we need to
descend we need to have distinct um
standard names for things that often
have same names right yeah but what is
the king of Norway 8721
Whatever It Is Well that yeah that
number I have no idea what that is
somebody in the where's the team would
have to say maybe
sorry go ahead
uh is there years in which the the
kingdom existed
eight right 72 and 1397. so maybe you
should say entity you should you should
make the actual entity objects out of
these so that we can see their common
names because you the canonical names
honestly don't matter yeah
uh uh that's a big fail guys first of
all how did you manage to cover the of
capitalized
that's a fail
this is pretty bad
there's ones with the double colon
things are because they apparently don't
have a naming property populated either
I've been Ben Ben and I were looking at
this after the last meeting there's
there's name missing names and name
cleanup that needs to be done and I'm
not sure
there's a big mess right we've got
Denmark Norway we've got Sweden and
Norway
I mean if it says okay
okay we've clearly got to do better
curation on these names
these are pretty horrible
and
I mean if we're really going to have
different entities but every disjoint
sequence of dates the way we should
probably do that is to say Norway paren
you know 872 to 1397.
you see what I'm saying in this in the
in the common name I think there are
some that are like that
okay so this may just be bad curation
here
could use this sub-label property like
we've done in some other domains that
would put a gray yeah that's what I
meant with the date ranges in there
that's exactly that would be something
we could we could programmatically
populate that property and then it would
format all the yellow boxes that way
okay but now Kingdom of Norway right is
it not still the kingdom of Norway
so it's why is it called Kingdom of
Norway back in the 1814 period
but now it's just called Norway
you see what I'm saying
I mean did somebody add Kingdom of just
as a way to disambiguate that period of
Norway's history
because that will be silly
so this is I mean for better or worse
this is by the way a convention I think
Wikipedia does too or like if you look
up Norway it's page would just be called
Norway but if you look up some
historical thing it might say Kingdom of
Norway or you know
you know yeah this is something that
they do with some regularity I think
it's a bit of a hack
maybe part of the thing is I think names
are are kind of ill-defined historically
I think this may be a political thing in
the in the sense of emphasizing the fact
that the previous entity was constructed
around the king but now the king is just
I think there is still a king actually
there is a king but doesn't have as much
power as
the king had before
I see it may have something to do with
the formal way that the country is known
internationally
and the United Nations
it might have a structure like the
Democratic monarchy but it's known as
Norway
right for example in in Spain we do have
a king now but speaking of the Kingdom
would be could be considered Politically
Incorrect
but yet the UK by its very name is the
United Kingdom yes yes
hmm
I mean this is obviously a horrifying
can of worms question is what can we do
that will actually be useful
right and I mean clearly
I think these modifiers like Kingdom of
and certainly medieval Kingdom of Norway
boy what are we doing at least that one
I understand what it means I mean that
one is is actually I mean even if it's a
little awkward it's it's
I know it's nothing about that is a
post-talk
all of these are fairly post-talk like a
lot of these I mean the idea of
countries having well-defined names and
stuff like that is extremely modern
but wait a minute on maps that you know
Ptolemy and people made they have names
of areas didn't they I mean they had
names like not like this not like this I
mean they'd have names of cities sure
I mean like even like Rome calling it
Roman Republic and Roman Empire is very
modern
I mean if we were being historical maybe
we'd write like spqr or something but
we're obviously not going to do that
right
um
well yeah but
okay
um
humph and to give another example of
where it gets complicated something like
one of these Sweden Norway or Union
between Sweden and Norway you know
that's because there were things where
the king of Sweden was also the king of
Norway so maybe you have in this two
countries maybe you have them as one
depending on how you know how in charge
the king of Sweden actually is in Norway
and and and it's like
right and there isn't necessarily a name
for that Union other than just the guy
who who is the king of both
yes did that happen
I don't know my British history like
William of Orange wasn't he somehow the
king of the some somehow the
somehow the Netherlands and and but
nevertheless those were considered as
two separate countries
maybe it was just one family I don't
really know I don't know the history
well enough
um okay what are we gonna do all right
so
okay first point is we have
what we might call history book names
for things
so first point is are we using is our
convention that we are using the history
book name for a country
seems like that's our convention so that
means Petty Norway whatever that is
should be called Petty Norway in its
standard name not just Norway
am I making sense you mean in its
display name yes yes correct
and arguably
it will be helpful to people to put
these gray sub comments for all of the
norway-like entities maybe we should do
that for every historical country to
give it span
because that will disambiguate it
you know for many of these things where
the name is somewhat arbitrary like
Kingdom of Norway versus medieval
Kingdom of Norway to give you know it's
not a lot of space to give the
parenthetical with the with the dates
but that seems like it's useful what do
people think of that
I think that might make some sense
but look at the standard names of the
last two things here Sweden Norway and
Union Sweden Norway I mean that's just
horrifying
you know
again
look and then we've got at the beginning
there we've got Denmark Norway so let's
make up our mind if we're going to if
there is unless there is a okay
maybe history book reasons for that like
you know oh before they were just two
two kingdoms under one king but then
later they actually merged their
administrations and so you know now now
you change their name I think putting
dates though would make a lot of those
problems less important because because
even if the names sound similar you can
just immediately see oh yes of course
this is the Sweden Norway from before
the great merger of blah blah blah
right
fine
and um
okay I I think in general in the
curation of these names that you know
things that are really written out with
a lot of words like Union between I
think we should try to avoid that
as we have in most other things
you know and and go for Sweden Norway
rather than Sweden and Norway if if
that's correct right
Alan
that's kind of for you
yeah sorry I'm just I'm just looking at
some stuff on my screen too yeah I I yes
I think you're great
can we get a list let's just do this
let's just see how horrifying it is
um
oh a lot of them okay we got all kinds
of crazy stuff here West Pakistan k5w7w
why the heck
I mean I understand what that was but
why does it have to have an identifier
there was only one nope it shouldn't
it's it shouldn't have an identifier
here if that's showing up it's because
the Entity framework is using the
standard Name by default because
somebody hasn't populated the name
property so this this is a mess so we
need
Okay so we've got things like
C parents State that's obviously
ridiculous
right this is badly curated
so
West Florida was not a thing was West
Florida very briefly
huh I think it was like one fort
during what during the Revolutionary War
or what
um I think a bit later but yeah okay so
somehow we've got Yan coming up this is
a mess guys this is a mess we need to
clean this up
okay but then we we kind of know what
we're going to do here it's going to be
basically civilized names that are
shortened you see look look we don't
want to do this County parent duchy of
berg make up your mind
let's plan for no parents
okay
and uh
yeah yeah right the Ankara government
I'm suspicious about that I'm suspicious
that I was just Ankara I mean you know
in other words the question is and okay
so here here's a question like you say
Bhopal state
right
is that really right or should it just
have been Bhopal here
look at what I'm saying I mean it
my gosh there was a thing called The
bamana Republic as opposed to the Banana
Republic
there is a Wikipedia page for a thing
called the Bhopal State and it's called
Bhopal state for what it's worth
yeah but I wouldn't consider that
necessarily right either no sure sure I
mean so
okay the question is we've got the
anuroo DAP whatever it was some looks
looks Asian at least Kingdom
and we've got Andorra which has probably
been a kingdom at some point
but we are so I mean the question of
whether we call something
yeah I think it just has to be whatever
the historical convention is that we
call it you know like we're not going to
call it United Kingdom we're not going
to cut off the kingdom part because
that's just part of its name
oh God I'm really upset with this
curation is so bad
um
well okay but we'll get this fixed all
right what what do we Okay so I think we
have a sort of a plan here the issue is
in terms of the linguistics
I think we probably should if you type
Norway
probably one of the choices should be
you know should be historical country
and then we could have multiple norways
listed there by their dates which would
include the kingdom of Norway the
medieval Kingdom of Norway
Etc Alan what do you think
I think it's not a bad idea I think
we've talked about it before and shied
away from that but it's that's a thing
that will require some it's going to
require more curation yeah which which
which things actually deserve to get
Norway added to their yeah for example
for example does Sweden you know does
Denmark Norway
you know is that you know somebody has
to really look at that is that something
that is reasonably thought of I mean
because if you say
you know
if you say Lithuania should you get the
Polish Lithuanian Union thing that we
just saw up here Commonwealth what do
you think I mean yes please
is that very strong opinion yeah we
really would like to have a good
relationships with our neighbor
Lithuania
and there were a big part of the
Commonwealth so I think both you know no
no but the question is it could be the
case that if you just say Lithuania
right that
in the spellings you simply don't get
the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
because that is considered a different
thing
you see what I'm saying as opposed to
it's not a thing you know it could have
been the kingdom of Lithuania the duchy
of Lithuania the whatever of Lithuania
and those are all Lithuania and
considered Lithuania whereas this thing
I mean like for example if you say
Poland I don't think you want to get
Prussia
because it's really you'd name it
differently if you wanted Prussia you
would have asked for Prussia I would
think
am I wrong I mean I don't know that part
of the world well enough but I don't
think you know I don't think you would
consider Prussia to be a you know a
dated
aspect to Poland right no but
um
I would say that polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth it says that you have you
know Lithuanian part of that and point
polish part of that
so
um
I know where you're going because you're
going on the on a space continuum and
I'm going on a more political logical
Continuum here well there's also the
naming Continuum because there's also
things like for example if you put
Russia should you also get USSR
presumably probably not
so maybe maybe the important thing is
when you say Poland you know the actual
phrasing is ambiguous whether you mean
pulling Lithuania or modern Poland
actually actually you know look Russia
back in you know in the 1970s for
example if somebody said Russia
they would have meant that would have
been a name that they could have used
for the Soviet Union
right but now someone says Russia they
pretty clearly don't mean the Soviet
Union because if they wanted to say
Soviet Union they would have just said
it or Soviet Russia or something like
that I see what you're saying I see what
you're saying you're saying that today
were you to be referring to the
historical thing you would not call it
Russia I don't know about that I don't
know about that
I mean then they're really horrifying
ones like for example people routinely
well they're dealing with people from
some parts of the country but will
routinely refer to England when they
mean the United Kingdom
right I think the thing to do is to do
it by whether the name is ambiguous
right if someone types Poland they might
actually mean Poland Lithuania or modern
Poland or whatever but if someone types
you know well actually I don't think you
know that I mean Gosha might know that
but I don't think without knowing
something about the local so to speak I
don't think we know that I mean it could
have been like if somebody said
um Ottoman Empire and then they said
turkey
you know those are but see those are you
can tell it's not just my point is that
I think if you try and do it politically
by saying well is turkey really a
successor of the Ottoman Empire then
then that's when you you you're in
trouble right but I think the thing is
in that case you would just say well did
they type ottoman or do they type turkey
because those names just the names just
as strings are clearly different yeah
and so you can tell the difference
unlike the Poland Lithuania case
right and I suppose and goal versus
France clearly different
but if you go to France and you say the
French Republic the French Revolutionary
Republic or whatever
those will not be distinguished
those those if you type France those
should be disambiguations for that but
Gaul
okay should Gaul be a disambiguation for
France
no especially because I doubt there is a
gallon here because there wasn't really
a unified one
okay
famously it was divided into three parts
did they did they have names I don't
know but there are things like in France
you bring up France but it's a
particularly complicated one because
again you know there's like France is on
like the fifth Republic or something
like that and they refer to themselves
occasionally as the fifth Republic
and I think we do have entities for
previous republics if you know what I
mean yeah
yeah but that's fine but so so if you
say France it should just have a list of
the various republics with their dates
yeah
my suggestion by the way in the
disambiguation sequence would be that we
give the historical countries and we
sort them from most recent to least
recent
right and then in the disambiguation
yeah that would be I think that would be
relatively easy to programmatically
score those but okay but but so okay so
what are we concluding here what we're
concluding is this needs a curation pass
the good news is it's only 3200 by
entities
um
and we just got to come up with
reasonable names for everything and
we've got to come up with the question
of
whether that thing like for example
you know
the ahorn kingdom I don't know what it
is but well it's a bad example because I
have a clue what it is
um
Antarctica okay
uh
on autonomous province of Western Bosnia
oh my gosh what do we do with that you
say Bosnia
does that come out up in the
disambiguation
if that had been most of Bosnia it
should surely come up in the
disambiguation but if it was a splinter
piece of Bosnia what should happen
I think the disambiguation should be
fairly liberal and just include
everything that's plausible
okay fine it's fine if it has 10 things
as it will if you put in something like
France
yeah okay so you're saying that even if
like you know Vichy France or whatever
else will show up
well that one would be that one's an
easy one but but even okay so question
is if it was a a tiny Splinter thing I
don't know the the um
uh the self-proclaimed you know not
quite sea land but some other
um you know plenty of parts of the world
where this happens far too much of of
you know some some small region will
will claim itself independent and for a
year it will it will survive as
independent and then it will be
reabsorbed I don't think it's too
embarrassing to include that in the
primary country and it's the same I
think that's fine but I think that the
criteria should be the name right I mean
maybe the this Western autonomous region
of Bosnia or whatever it's uh called you
know should yeah maybe it mostly was
actually in modern Montenegro but I
think we shouldn't we should still only
disambiguate it for bars in the air
because that's you know that's the thing
that's in the name
to that point I will give you counter
example uh Warsaw dachi
should show up for Poland yep it was a
little bleep when Napoleon was coming
and you know liberated part of Poland
and then he went to and had the bad bad
time at Moscow so everything disappeared
but yeah the name the names are you know
the the problem with just following the
name convention is that she's gonna lose
this briefs like that that you know it
had completely different name but might
have political significance
right but the question is if someone
puts in Poland and we're trying to
disambiguate it are we trying to find
all the things that were quote-unquote
polish or are we trying to to only find
the things that you know assuming that
they know the names of different things
what could they be referring to because
right right but maybe you know but but
but but maybe we can have you know just
just a binary disambiguation in the way
that you know porn do you mean the you
know current or a historic entity and
then from from you know if somebody
wants a historic historic entity then
you can direct to the slew of of you
know of possibilities yeah we're
definitely going to have that that
initial Branch for sure
but
you know the issue is how far afield
because if somebody said
I don't know I don't know history well
enough but I mean in
what you're saying is basically look it
seems to me there are two criteria
either it's a name maybe maybe we do it
Union of two things it's either it's got
a name like the Western autonomous
region of Bosnia
or it is the significant geographic area
or it has a significant overlap of
geographic area in other words I don't
think
okay so this is a good question if you
say Estonia
should you get Soviet Union for some
part of Estonia and I think the answer
is no and I think the Criterion the
reason for that is there's two
possibilities either if it was there you
know if it was the duchy of Estonia or
something for some period of time then
great you you get that and or if there
was a thing whose borders were decently
agreeing with Estonia but it was called
squiggleroo instead you still you get
that there's a few so if you had modern
Italy should you also include the Roman
Republic because for five minutes it had
similar borders
okay um Stephen question back at you if
I say England should I say United
Kingdom or Great Britain
wait a minute wait wait wait which we
have an entity right now called United
Kingdom well yeah but book you say so so
the point is that Estonia was was in the
Union of Soviet Republic right yeah so
England is in a union is in the United
Kingdom right
so if you if you disambiguate England
you only go for the English or can you
go also for for the for the for the
unions that England is part of because
if if from England you you show United
Kingdom then from Estonia uh you know in
a historic countries you you would you
would look England
okay I'm sure that we do what do we do
here
I think if you do anything like that
there's probably a well it's just UK
yeah no it's it's no it isn't it's the
administrative division
okay okay uses a country
they're also they're historical okay
there you go but they're also I think
there are historical countries called
England there are two different variants
England
yes I'm sure
right and I'm sure when when um
you know when Ms bodacia was in charge
it had you know it wasn't I guess it
wasn't that big a country then but but
um
uh
let's see I mean
okay
what should happen here so by the way
England probably during the Civil War
did it change its name maybe it didn't
have a well-defined name
because certainly if it was a kingdom
before it wasn't a kingdom for a brief
period of time
okay this is the sort of thing where it
probably was amorphous what its name was
the idea that it had a well-defined name
that was publicized everywhere is not a
historical probably
yeah I mean but it probably had a flag
which that's also a very modern thing
that everyone's excited to have one flag
yeah but didn't they have when they were
like in you know when they were like the
standards for and battles and things
didn't they have to have something
otherwise didn't know yeah but they were
often not very flag-like and not what
you associate with like the idea of like
countries having well-defined names
borders and flags is like you know only
became really solidified in like the
1800s yeah
okay so what are we going to do here
this is I mean so
okay so I think Alan has to do it you
know get somebody to do a QA should pass
on this and figure out what some of the
horrifying issues are I think we've got
okay Gosha was raising the question of
if something
look
the basic point
you might be right if something was
incorporated into let's say the Soviet
Union why not listed in the historical
country list it's useful
because
in fact it's useful in the following way
you say I really want to know about
Estonia in 1983.
why can't I find that all these people
just you know
are they you know did they just mess up
mess up the curation well the reason you
can't find it is that the country didn't
exist in 1983.
so it would be better for us to list the
list of the stack of things with
contiguous dates that just says you know
Soviet Union 1945 or whatever it was to
1989 or whatever
for Estonia does that make sense to
people
I mean that seems more useful and now
having said that
what is the programmatic way
I mean I could do it by just saying um
you know interpreter by the way I assume
we have start and end dates for every
for every historical country I assume
that that's a property
date interval or something
we certainly have yeah our properties
okay I think I I don't think they're
guaranteed to be defined but they are
properties
how could they not be defined well I
mean we certainly wouldn't have politics
I found one that I don't even know what
it is called Abby of Saint Peter and the
black forest which has basically nothing
to find but I don't even know what it is
there's probably some
you know somebody running the Abbey said
we're declaring independence well I
looked it up and all I could find was
the building and it was a monastery or
something sorry go ahead whoever was
well do we have sea land
talking of herself we've talked about
sea land in the past but I don't think
we've ever decided where that would
if it was anything it would be a
historic country but what is confusing
about sea land is it has no polygons
well no I mean there are tons of things
like this but this is not it's not
recognized no one I don't think anyone
really ever recognized sea land just as
no one ever recognized one of 50 other
uh
has another awkward point which is every
other country has a border that is part
of a continent does it not
in other words when we give the borders
of a country we're not giving them out
into the ocean
it's like you know Kiribati or something
like island nations yeah I understand so
what do we do there what do we do for
the polygon we the polygon is the land
of Kiribati isn't it
but we have this we have discussed
having the maritime borders it will be
very useful because sometimes people do
a query about a point which is just in
the mouth of a river or something like
that and we say false
just because it's in the water and we
shouldn't
right well that makes sense I mean but
if we have Maritime borders that
includes you know where they are on the
fish type thing presumably
and when the flight embargo it's imposed
yeah because you have the the
international waters versus you know
territorial Waters yes
the
although I think that there are many
more disputes about that because you
know you can if it's on the land people
notice because somebody's got their
house and it's in country X or country y
if it's in the ocean you can get away
with a lot more fuzziness about who owns
that you know who who whether it's
territorial Waters or not I don't know
how much I mean if there's a there's
supposed to be a an equation for it
basically but in fact it doesn't follow
in lots of places and I mean it's the
same thing as on land I mean they're
territorial disputes and you know in the
water as well as on land
yeah fair enough I mean okay all right
we should probably wrap up this meeting
unfortunately but I think we have made
progress on this issue and on the time
series issue the other biggest zoo that
we had here was what
what was the other big thing that we
were trying to discuss here
so I think the time series we've got got
a resolution yeah go ahead yeah I wanted
to discuss uh um how do we treat the
historical countries either by putting
new uh functions for like temporal
entities or just include them in the Geo
functions
yes last time we discussed this the
whole space-time story of these
countries yes we ended up with that yes
that's our third option
we're not going to get away without
things significantly different from that
I mean we may be able to you know we
should take that as the kind of ground
truth and then we should decide what
projections of it we want to have is my
point of view
so in other words and I think Francisco
had made this nice
uh graphic of the space-time structure
of the Roman Empire
um
but you know and obviously we don't have
the full space-time envelope because we
only have it at discrete time points
here's a question for Gosha in in the
time series redesign
what are you going to do with uh uh
geometric Time series
with polygons yeah times the result
polygons well then by default they will
have the hold value from the left
indication in a way
but you don't have any other plan for
that like is there something that the
region functionality with all of our
region reconstruction surface
reconstruction stuff could do not
necessarily for the country case but I'm
just trying to understand what's out
there
because what's going to happen is given
that we have the thing that has you know
piecewise linear
you know well piecewise constant
uh polygons then we're going to have all
of the stuff about the intersection of
this space-time region with that one
oh boy
is it Johan did you crystallize this
beyond what we talked about last time is
this more crystallized to something
which we can talk about or is this still
in the same state it was before no this
is more or less the same we didn't
finish discussing this
it didn't make sense to move forward
okay all right fine
well I think we're going to have to
um have another meeting perhaps yep I
think we have to have another meeting
um but I mean I think basically what
your
right I mean do you want us to explore
anything else in the meantime no but
this curation needs to get done and I
think this curation may help us
understand
I mean the basic question here was
let's see for a given point
okay there's some well-defined things
like for this point give me the time
series of what countries it's been in
are making sense
yeah yes
that seems well defined
um and then
what what's what's this stuff again here
what was this Geo Group doing again
is a collection of all the bullions for
the entity without dates
all right so that's like the union
region
yeah right it's just a bad name I think
it's a perfectly fine concept it's just
like all the polygons we have
I mean it could just be called
historical polygons
well nobody comes back oh no sorry it
doesn't come back I thought the idea was
that it would come back as a Geo Group
object though so you could run Geo area
on it and stuff like that
oh I see I see
I see it it doesn't right now no no but
it doesn't yeah look it does here no
because you said to your group around it
that was one of the things we talked
about last time is in fact it was called
Geo Group because it had an analogy to
Geo Group but it didn't actually return
one
well that makes sense I didn't remember
we had a thing called Geo Group what is
Geo Group
it's a analogy of Graphics group
or the geocontext
well I think the idea is that if you
said something like Geo area of that I
think it would give you the right area
as opposed to a list of areas or
something like that if Geo areas have
been listable
yeah let's see if this thing
although it's not if the polygons
overlap it's a non-trivial calculation
so I honestly don't know how that works
well I mean let's see if the Geo area of
this
okay and if I take it now make sure it's
not the sum because the sun's gonna be
the wrong answer
wrong answer
I think that's the wrong answer Jose
what do you think I think it's the wrong
answer I think Geo Group should
correctly
sort of you know should just be a single
a single covering so to speak of every
point
let's say that the in the Geo
context we typically assume the polygons
do not overlap that you have already
prepared things because if we have to
stop at every moment to intersect
potentially thousands of polygons
it could be
complicated okay but then this Geo Group
property it just doesn't make sense
right well maybe the thing to do is I
mean right now we don't have good ways
of doing for example you know unions of
geopolygons if we did
wouldn't the right thing to be do just
to return a single geopolygon that is
the Union
right
yes so so that's a
separate operation
so yeah we pre-compute that there is
your group was more like
like the other Graphics group The the
fact that you put this there and then
you cannot select individual parts and
things like that it's more like a
graphical
think but we have used it for other
reasons
right so so geo geo groups continue to
do this but but the geovariant that we
saw in the other notebook you know
presumably should maybe for now it can
return you know maybe you'd call it a
union region or something like that or
or or you know area or
sure but well but but initially maybe it
would return the Geo Group and then once
we can actually compute the the unions
or maybe we can compute the unions you
know ourselves right now
then we can do that
right
okay we should wrap this up for now
[Music]
um
next time
I mean if you guys had a chance to think
some more about this site it will be
good I you know
uh
right I mean you're basically saying
okay
let me just summarize a couple of things
here I mean
you're basically saying
for every historical country
there's a maximum expansion
there's the Geo Union
right those are two things Geo Group is
just not going to make it as a name
and we should just consider
the maximum expansion is itself a
polygon it has properties right maximum
expansion
what is that I mean okay it's got a
polygon it's probably got a population
it's might even have a date of Maximum
expansion as opposed to the union region
which is
you know the thing projected in the
space-time blob is just looking in the
space Direction and just Union it in the
time Direction
as opposed to maximum expansion which is
looking at the maximum area point in
space time
if I understand correctly
is that right yes that's right
okay what's this case here
what does that mean dated polygon is the
time series of polygons the space-time
thing
oh boy he was then looking at
is looking at the question of whether
these were disjoint as space-time snakes
so to speak
but that doesn't okay but for example if
it was Gaul and France or the gallic
Empire in France okay
those are disjoint in time but not
disjoint in space
so I think what we need is a geo within
queue that is a space-time Geo within
queue right which is because both of
those are relevant I mean we we can both
ask
and that and and that's why we arise
with it with a you know temporal
functions
starts to treat separately the the
geographic part and the
temporal part
yes well which we're going to need to do
but maybe those just turn into time
series and then we have a a reasonable
set of Time series comparison functions
um
all right
uh time to go for now I think we have a
good place to start next time and maybe
you could try to
you know we've we've already figured out
a certain amount here we could try and
clean this up a bit based on what we've
already figured out
by the way this business about dated not
taking a naked integer I really think we
should just fix that it's just silly
well but but
everywhere if you give it a date spec
and it's an integer it assumes it's an
absolute time
yes but I think dated should be
different I think it can be and it
should be because I get this wrong every
single time it's just kind of stupid you
know dated most of the time is just a
year
1700 seconds after whatever it is 1970
or something is just not what you want
the case would not be typing it the case
would be if you did it programmatically
I mean it's the same with data object
where data object of 1900 looks very
natural but it can't work
no I understand that but dated doesn't
have to follow exactly the same
conventions as date object
although I think every date function
follows that convention right now I know
but I'm saying dated could be different
because it's because it is used so often
for these entity things that are year
granularity type things I mean look
dated
could have the way we could do it is now
that we have a date granularity option
we could have a default date granularity
option here that somehow I don't know
but that doesn't quite work
but there are cases there like for
example if you're dealing with time
series that you know there's a way of
getting out the list of data objects
there's also a way of getting out the
list of absolute times and then you can
programmatically use those in all sorts
of places but if they work everywhere to
get the absolute times except for
withdated in The Entity framework I
think that would be weird further
discussion required okay to be continued
see you all soon
bye